Timothy is fresh off his Golden Globe
nomination for his role as Willie Wonka
in Wonka now his interpretation of the
Beloved chocolate teer follows iconic
turns from Jean Wilder and Johnny de in
this brand new original musical fantasy
I'm sorry you're the rock star of
Toronto right now oh man um screaming
this is amazing yeah Happ to be here
listen this is your first movie musical
I mean we saw those viral videos of you
performing in your high school in those
musicals no they're amazing musical
stuff would say it's awful that's stuff
I'm proud of no you're great your
rapping skills Next Level what I would
say is awful that's what I would say is
awful how nerve-wracking was it what for
you that first time you had to sing on
set how nerve-wracking was that for you
it was very nerve-wracking cuz I don't
really that's not really my background
and and uh the original movies beloved
so I didn't want to you know ruin it
what was trickier dancing or singing
both doing both at the same time same
time yeah yeah did you feel like there
was a moment where you actually got it
how long did that take like halfway
through the movie yeah yeah yeah is
everyone supporting you do you have
moments where you're calling people
being like am I doing this the right
thing yeah absolutely often with my mom
my sister are much better at that kind
of thing than I am but uh I don't know
we had an amazing dance troop and I felt
well supported and it wasn't live so
there's a lot of bad stuff they didn't
make it in the movie you know what I
mean so congrats on tonight Carolyn and
Jeff judging from the reaction from the
Canadian fans on this carpet I think
it's safe to say that Timothy has
another sweet hit on his hands back to
you both in studio all all right thank
you very much Morgan and again a
reminder that Wonka opens in theaters
coming up tomorrow